[Musik]
phoenix vor ort
schönen guten abend meine damen und
herren ich begrüße jetzt auch die
zuschauer des zweiten deutschen
fernsehens zdf bei uns wir wollen ihnen
einen überblick geben über die situation
zwischen russland der ukraine aber auch
über die neuigkeiten des tages
informieren die russischen truppen
stehen offenbar nur noch circa 30
kilometer vor kiew der hauptstadt der
ukraine der formaxx habe sich so mit
experten und beobachter offenbar
verlangsamt dies liege an logistischen
problemen und einer stärkeren als der
erwarteten gegenwert der ukrainischen
soldaten die bundesregierung hat heute
entgegen der bisherigen absicht
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
beschlossen es handelt sich um
panzerfäuste und haubitzen in der
ukraine ist heftiger widerstand gegen
die invasion zu sehen eine sehr große
rolle bei den sanktionen spielt die
frage ob russland aus dem
zahlungsverkehr zwischen ausgeschlossen
werden soll bis auf deutschland haben
alle länder bisher dafür plädiert nun
hat auch deutschland zugestimmt und wir
können ihnen zeigen und wir können ihnen
präsentieren die kommissionspräsidentin
von der leyen die das programm von swift
vorgestellt hat
der europäischen union entfernt verübt
die russische armee barbarische taten
sie wirft bomben und feuert raketen auf
unschuldige menschen
und zugleich ist die ganze welt zeuge
des entschlossenen und mutigen
widerstandes der ukrainischen armee und
bevölkerung
die russischen streitkräfte setzten mit
unverminderter härte ihre angriffe auf
kiew und andere ukrainische städte fort
vor diesem hintergrund sind wir
entschlossener denn je
russland einen preis so hoch wie
irgendwie möglich für diese aggression
aufzuerlegen und das land weiter vom
internationalen finanzsystem und
wirtschaftlich zu isolieren
in abstimmung mit präsident biden
bundeskanzler scholz präsident makro und
premierminister draghi als auch
premierminister trude und
premierminister johnson werden wir die
internationale antwort auf die russische
aggression weiter schaffen
ich werde den staats und regierungschefs
der europäischen union und die folgenden
neuen maßnahmen vorschlagen erstens wir
wollen sicherstellen dass eine anzahl
russischer banken aus swift
ausgeschlossen wird
dieser schritt wird die betroffenen
banken weitgehend vom internationalen
finanzsystem abkoppeln und
dieser schritt wird es ihnen erheblich
erschweren am weltweiten geschäfts
verkehr teilzunehmen
swift ist das dominierende globale
zahlungssystem zwischen banken
ohne schrift werden die betroffenen
banken kaum mehr in der lage sein
finanztransaktionen auf dem weltmarkt
durchzuführen und damit blockieren wir
auch weitgehend russische exporte und
importe
zweitens wir wollen putin daran hindern
seine staatlichen rücklagen für die
finanzierung seines krieges zu nutzen
dafür werden wir das vermögen der
russischen zentralbank blockieren ihre
transaktionen werden eingefroren und wir
nehmen die der zentralbank die
möglichkeit ihre guthaben international
einzusetzen
der dritte punkt betrifft oligarchen wir
arbeiten intensiv daran dass sie über
ihre geldvermögen nicht mehr
unbeschränkt verfügen können
mit all diesen maßnahmen erschweren wie
es putin seinen krieg gegen die ukraine
zu finanzieren und wir holen die
fundamente der russischen wirtschaft
nach und nach aus
putin hat einen kurs gewählt der auf die
zerstörung der ukraine abzielt aber
damit zerstört er ebenfalls die zukunft
seines eigenen landes
der ausschluss russlands aus dem
internationalen zahlungsverkehr swift
wird die russische wirtschaft massiv
treffen das kann man jetzt und sagen
aber wie funktioniert eigentlich 12
wenn irgendwo auf der welt eine
auslandsüberweisung stattfindet kommt
swift ins spiel mit dem eigentlichen
bankgeschäft hat das nichts zu tun der
kommunikationsdienstleister sorgt an
seinem eher unscheinbaren sitz in der
nähe brüssels vielmehr dafür dass
informationen über zahlungen sicher und
schnell ausgetauscht werden im zentrum
stehen dabei standardisierte formulare
mit dem identifikations code bic der nur
zu einer einzigen bank führt er besteht
aus elf zeichen die ersten vier stehen
für den bank nahm dann kommt der
ländercode dann die ortskennung und
gegebenenfalls die filiale kennung oder
einfach 3x verwechslung ausgeschlossen
weltweit sind 11.000 banken und
finanzkonzerne in über 200 ländern in
diesem netzwerk miteinander verbunden
auf grundlage der swift informationen
buchen sie zahlungen und es wirft kann
ein land kaum geld empfangen oder zahlen
und der handel wäre so extrem erschwert
in brüssel begrüße ich markus preiß
schon guten abend
genannt eine gemeinsame and ein
gemeinsamer entschluss russland auswirft
auszuschließen was bedeutet das für die
europäischen länder
also erst mal ist das ein signal
sozusagen der gemeinsamkeit denn das ist
auch ein risiko dass da eingegangen wird
wenn man diesen entschluss so fasst denn
diese die konsequenzen des ganzen die
sind einfach nicht absehbar es gibt
immer wieder stimmen von diversen
politikern beamten
auch außenminister gestern ganz konkret
die einfach sagen da ist ein großes
risiko auch dass man da vielleicht eine
finanzkrise mit auslöst trotzdem sagt
man das vorgehen russland das ist so
brutal man muss jetzt handeln und die
forderungen des swift ausschlusses die
steht da schon länger im raum deswegen
wird man wahrscheinlich so sich
entscheiden und das ist natürlich ein
klares signal an moskau dass man eben
jetzt auch wirklich die handschuhe
ausziehen jetzt hat man ein entschluss
der bundesregierung nämlich 4000
panzerfäuste zu liefern haubitzen und 14
gepanzerte fahrzeuge es gibt also jetzt
waffenlieferungen aus deutschland wie
ist das in der eu angekommen
ich würde es mal so sagen mit
erleichterung das ist ja etwas wo
deutschland sehr stark für in der kritik
stand wo es hier weniger verstanden
haben warum man selbst in einer solchen
situation immer noch so zögerlich ist
und aus sicht vieler eu-staaten so
formalistisch argumentiert alle kennen
die deutsche geschichte alle wissen dass
da deutschland sensibler ist aber zu
sagen man liefert keine waffen in
konfliktgebiete während man gleichzeitig
ganz große waffendeals zum beispiel mit
ägypten abschließt das versteht in
dieser situation niemand wo man diese
bilder aus der ukraine sieht wo man
männer sieht die sagen wir gehen dorthin
wir wollen da kämpfen und den dann zu
sagen wir liefern euch aber trotzdem
nicht es hat hier keiner verstanden so
gesehen würde ich sagen da gibt es ein
aufatmen dass das eben jetzt aus
deutschland auch passiert wobei allen
klar ist auch die waffenlieferung werden
das generelle kräfteverhältnis zwischen
russland und der ukraine jetzt nicht
fein der ukrainische präsident lsg hat
noch einmal nachdrücklich gefordert die
ukraine nun in die eu aufzunehmen
das ist ja sicherlich ein sozusagen
frommer wunsch aber hat man da in
irgendeiner form auf der eu ebene darauf
reagiert
man auf der eu ebene nicht aber einzelne
mitgliedstaaten sind beim eu gipfel vor
ein paar tagen auch schon mit der
forderung nie angekommen es gab sogar
einen offiziellen brief von polen und
slowenien die das auch gefordert haben
nur da ist wie sie selber gerade sagten
das ganze eher ein frommer wunsch denn
es geht nicht nur beim eu-beitritt um
ein politisches signal
so ungefähr wir unterstützen euch
deswegen konnte in der eu sondern gerade
dass es geht ja deutlich schwerer als
zum beispiel nato mitglied zu werden da
muss man einen sehr langen prozess
durchlaufen wo zum beispiel das
justizsystem angeglichen wird wo
wirtschaftsfragen geklärt werden wobei
hilfe fragen geklärt werden wo die frage
geklärt wird welche agrar subventionen
fließen dann die ukraine ist ein sehr
großes agrarland also wenn man sich das
mal praktisch vorstellt was es braucht
um eu mitglied zu werden dann sieht man
die politische forderung das signal das
wünschen sich vielleicht der eine oder
andere noch mehr aber praktisch macht
man das mit sicherheit so nicht herr
preis wir haben immer wieder in den
letzten monaten ja fast schon den
letzten jahren darüber gesprochen bei
gesprächen zwischen uns da gibt es
unterschiede in der eu andere meinungen
da gibt es sogar heftigen streit
innerhalb der eu seit tagen habe den
eindruck die eu steht bemerkenswert
zusammen ist sie auch in der lage mehr
oder weniger den ton anzugeben oder tut
das weiterhin washington
also ich würde sagen die erste
beobachtungen die sie haben die habe ich
auch das ist ein eu gipfel ist
normalerweise ein gipfel vom internen
streitigkeiten jetzt hat man da ganz
klar
außerhalb sozusagen den gegner will ich
fast sagen mit russland allen ist klar
wenn man dem nichts entgegen sitzt dann
wird auch diese ganze gemeinschaft in
frage gestellt werden weil man ja eben
sicherheitspolitisch da dann nichts mehr
ausschließen kann so gesehen
steht man da zusammen lässt viele
differenzen auch bei seite man sieht
auch entwicklungen jetzt zum beispiel
polen ist ein land das immer kritisiert
wurde dafür dass es keine flüchtlinge
aufnehmen will aber es polen sagt eben
jetzt mit offenen armen wir nehmen die
ukraine so viele wie wir verkraften
können irgendwann wird sicher der punkt
kommen wo der rest der eu da auch noch
mal stärker helfen muss morgen treffen
sich ja die innenminister auch genau zu
diesem thema hier aber man sieht daher
rückt man zusammen und das ist einfach
eine situation die existenziell
wahrgenommen wird und da ist das
kleinklein sag ich mal was man sonst
häufig hat er hat zweitrangig
verkaufspreis in brüssel ganz herzlichen
dank
gerne im studio begrüße ich joachim
weber schon guten abend sie sind
sicherheitsforschern gastprofessor an
der universität in bonn bevor wir über
swift reden das müssen wir gleich noch
mal tun wir haben das sagen wir mal an
waffenlieferungen was die europäischen
länder außer der bundesrepublik
deutschland ständig verlangt haben jetzt
seit heute abend ich habe die zahl
dessen genannt was doch geliefert wird
an die ukraine was haben die für eine
strategische bedeutung was bringt diese
waffenlieferung tatsächlich für die
kämpfe in der ukraine gegen russland
also diese waffen die punkten das
vielleicht noch vorweg zu sagen es sei
ein bemerkenswerter
sinneswandel aber in der tat das ist
eine neue situation die wir jetzt haben
das ist ein gewaltiger schritt für die
deutsche politik und ja die frage was
nun daraus dem dem lieferung dieser
waffen zu erwarten ist die ist nicht so
ganz einfach zu beantworten
andy
panzer waffen also panzerfäuste sind
natürlich nützlich gegen einen feind der
mit mechanisierten kräften vorrückt in
der ukraine sehr viel größere bedeutung
messe ich der lieferung dieses thema
luft abwehrraketen zu wenn es gelingt
die tatsächlich auch zu den ukrainischen
truppen zu bekommen und die genug auch
leute haben die in der lage sind diese
waffen hatte quad einzusetzen dann kann
das für die russen sehr schmerzhaft
werden denn im moment können sie auf der
basis einer wahrscheinlich fast totalen
luft herrschaft über der ukraine
operieren ich weiß nicht inwieweit die
ukrainische luftabwehr derzeit noch ein
tag des man hört von abschüssen von
flugzeugen also völlig niedergekämpft
kann sie nicht sein anscheinend aber
dennoch wird es einen abwehrnetz mit
großen lücken seien also die lufthoheit
haben die russen über der ukraine und
das könnte für sie ein wirklich
empfindliches problem werden nun haben
wir im zusammenhang mit all dem was dort
passiert ist aber auch bei früheren
konflikten mit generellen hier
gesprochen im studio und haben die
gefragt wie ist das denn mit der
luftüberlegenheit dann haben die immer
wieder gesagt das ist das eine aber der
sieg oder die sozusagen eroberung kann
nur auf dem boden stattfinden das würde
aber bedeuten dass es da im zweifelsfall
bei dem widerstand jetzt zu erkennen ist
in der ukraine
gerade auch um kiew doch zu sehr sehr
schlimmen gefechten kommen dürfe das ist
auch genau das problem der russen die
ukraine leistet die ukrainischer medien
offenkundig erbitterten und teils auch
sehr erfolgreichen widerstand und nach
allem was wir wissen und auch auf den
karten jahr verzeichnet sehen sind ja
relativ kleine gelände einbrüche um das
wird eher schmal zu sagen bisher in das
territorium der ukraine gelungen was die
russen beherrschen sind offenkundig
einige zentral wichtige über landstraßen
die eben vor einigen in richtung kirche
in richtung der hauptstadt führen die
auch sehr nah an der an der russischen
grenze gelegen ist auf einer distanz dem
in in ein zwei tagen überbrückt werden
kann aber vielmehr scheinen die russen
auch bisher am boden nicht zu
beherrschen und für die ukrainischen
streitkräfte ist es sicherlich
angesichts der russischen luft über
legen hat sehr schwer sich den russen in
offener feldschlacht gegenüberzustellen
dann werden sie wahrscheinlich
geschlagen weil die russen mit
jagdbomber mit kampfhubschraubern und
dergleichen dann natürlich massiv
einwirken können aber in dem moment wo
sie sich ins bild der städte
zurückziehen wo also die sicht weg ist
für die kampfhubschrauber wo
straßenschluchten sind wo man dieses
ganze große gerät und die
luftstreitkräfte nicht in dem maße
einsetzen kann dann ist das ein anderes
spiel nicht und dann ist es einen kampf
fast schon mann gegen mann nicht dann
ist jedes haus einen ort wo schützen mit
sturmgewehren aber auch mit
panzerfäusten versteckt sein können dann
wird es schmerzhaft für die russen dann
müssen sie im häuser- und im
straßenkampf sich stück für stück
letzten endes jeden straßenzug erobern
und das kann ein sehr blutiges
unterfangen werden wir sprechen gleich
weiter ganz kurz aber noch die frage es
ist jetzt von putin angekündigt worden
diese invasion zu verstärken diese
offensive zu verstärken
was soll das heißen das sind spricht der
schon der sowjetischen und genauso der
heutigen russischen militärdoktrin dass
man in staffeln angreift die großen
greifen über in einer ersten und einer
zweiten staffel an und offenkundig haben
wir den angriff der ersten staffel der
ersten welle sozusagen jetzt gesehen der
ist allem anschein nach nicht so
verlaufen wie putin und die russische
seite sich das vorgestellt hat
wahrscheinlich hat man gedacht in einem
fast handstreichartig zugriff die
hauptstadt nehmen zu können das
regierungsviertel vielleicht zu sanieren
herrn selensky zu töten oder rauszuholen
um irgendwo vorzuführen was auch immer
die absicht dahinter sein mag ich denke
es wird jetzt sehr bald der angriff der
zweiten staffel beginnen und dann ist
die frage ob die logistik der ukraine
weiter her gibt sich dagegen auch noch
erfolgreich verteidigen zu können denn
streitkräfte brauchen nach und der ist
wahrscheinlich unter diesen bedingungen
sehr sehr schwer herzustellen
habe ich eben gesagt schon weiter wenn
wir auf swift kommen wir haben heute
eine deutliche äußerung des
oppositionsführers
friedrich merz gehört der sich für den
ausschluss russlands aus diesem system
ausgesprochen hat
hier stehen fast am ende eines weiteren
tages mit sich dramatisch zuspitzenden
ereignissen in der ukraine wir haben
heute den ganzen tag mit der
bundesregierung mit einzelnen vertretern
der bundesregierung mit den im bundestag
vertretenen parteien von spd fdp und
grünen über eine gemeinsame
vorgehensweise beraten
ich kann feststellen dass es uns
wahrscheinlich gelingt für den morgigen
tag eine gemeinsame entschließung in den
deutschen bundestag einzubringen in der
spd cdu csu fdp und grüne eine klare
position einnehmen zu dem was wir in
diesen tagen erleben aber auch zu den
konsequenzen die es aus unserer
gemeinsamen sich daraus gilt zu ziehen
sie haben mitbekommen dass es im laufe
des tages eine ganze reihe von
nachrichten gab um zwei fragen die eine
betrifft mögliche waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine die zweite betrifft die
einbeziehung von shift in das
sanktionsregime gegen russland zum thema
swift habe ich mich persönlich in den
letzten tagen häufig geäußert es ist ein
außergewöhnlich scharfes schwert einer
sanktion ich habe aber heute auch im
laufe des tages gegenüber den vertretern
der bundesregierung keinen zweifel daran
gelassen dass
ich persönlich aber auch wir als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion ist für geboten
halten jetzt auch swift in den kreis der
sanktionen aufzunehmen man muss dazu
technisch wissen dass trotz einer
suspension von trifft immer noch
rechnungen zu zahlen möglich bleibt auch
für energielieferungen aus russland
es gibt möglichkeiten die es trotzdem
noch zu vollziehen aber die lage die
sich heute im laufe des tages zusätzlich
ergeben hat mit einer völlig hemmung
loosen einbeziehung der zivilbevölkerung
in der ukraine in diesen angriffskrieg
erfordert aus unserer sicht jetzt eine
ganz klare eine sehr eindeutige
antwort die sämtliche optionen von
sanktionen auch einbezieht das trifft
sollte und muss nach unserer festen
überzeugung einbezogen werden in die
sanktionen die jetzt gegen russland
verhängt werden ich begrüße den
wirtschafts und finanzexperten ulrich
egger seiner schönen guten abend
haben gerade einen überblick noch mal
über dieses schriftsystem gesehen was
wir ja im prinzip auch kennen können sie
uns sagen was die folgen eines
ausschlusses führen für russland
bedeuten würden
das würde bedeuten dass der größte teil
des handels zwischen der westlichen welt
und russland
grunde unmittelbar nach diesem
inkrafttreten dieses beschlusses und das
würde innerhalb von stunden möglich sein
vorbei wäre denn das charmante sozusagen
als nicht aus sicht von unternehmen und
von banken ist es ist automatisiert das
ist standardisiert man kann also große
mengen von überweisungen damit erledigen
und auf der anderen seite ist es sicher
und das ist natürlich für banken dazu
wichtig wenn das nicht mehr gegeben ist
dann fällt man zurück im grunde auf ein
system der handarbeit man muss quasi
miteinander telefonieren man kann ein
fax schicken oder ein telex wie in den
90er jahren
das sind möglichkeiten aber sie merken
an den ball spielen bereits das macht
man den einzelnen geschäften aber nicht
mehr in der menge was heißt denn das
wenn dieser internationalen
zahlungsverkehr nicht mehr funktioniert
wenn man also sozusagen auf das fax und
andere dinge zurückgreifen muss die ja
im grunde genommen der vergangenheit
angehören
das heißt das große wichtige geschäfte
die auch von westlicher seite genehmigt
sind beispielsweise die deutschen
zahlungen für russisches öl und gas die
würden von deutscher seite und von den
beteiligten banken sicherlich noch
geleistet werden aber alles was
sozusagen den normalen handel mit
industrieprodukten mit dienstleistungen
angehen damit wäre es im grunde im
wesentlichen vorbei ausnahmen kann es
sicherlich für für
überweisungen sozialen bereich bei
angeles und ähnlichem geben alles was
unter entwicklungshilfe und wenn
beispielsweise auch da konnte man
ausnahmen machen aber der ganz normale
deutsche exporteure der würde einfach
sein geld nicht mehr gekommen und
deswegen wird er dann auch nicht mehr
exportieren und alle die sozusagen jetzt
als unternehmen doch offene rechnung
haben denn die müssen davon ausgehen
dieses geld dann im zweifel nicht mehr
zu bekommen nun hat das einen begriff
gegeben der nicht sehr schön ist das sei
eine atombombe für den finanz
transatlantischen und auch weltweiten
zahlungsverkehr ist das tatsächlich dann
eine so massive einschränkung dass
russland sehr stark davon betroffen ist
die russische wirtschaft wird davon
massiv betroffen seien die westlichen
wirtschaftssysteme werden soweit
betroffen seien mehr oder weniger das
ist davon abhängig wie intensiv der
handel des jeweiligen landes mit
russland ist deutschland wird sicherlich
am stärksten betroffen sein und wir
haben ja gesehen wir auch noch zögerlich
war in den vergangenen tagen italien
beispielsweise auch da gibt es ein
großes engagement
italiens in russland wirtschaftlich auch
italienischer banken das heißt sie
werden alle natürlich auch betroffen
sein man wird trotzdem noch weiter
zahlen können innerhalb russlands die
haben ein eigenes zahlungsverkehrssystem
das für den russischen verkehr geeignet
ist aber wenn irgendwas importiert und
bezahlt werden soll dann geht das eben
nicht mehr über das westliche
bankensystem im zweifel mit russland das
was sie brauchen und was sie bekommen
können dann vermutlich maschine
abwickeln die ebenfalls ein eigenes
zahlungssystem haben aber das wird alles
nicht glatt laufen dass das wird rumpeln
und krachen und der russischen
wirtschaft massiv schaden
sie haben es gerade angedeutet in der
bundesrepublik haben weil der regierung
erste zweifel gehabt an der aussetzung
von 12 nun hat man zugestimmt hat aber
gesagt wir wollen da eine einschränkung
haben wir sollten die aussehen
naja die einschränkung könnte so
aussehen wie ich das gerade geschrieben
habe dass man sozusagen von dem
automatisierten standardverfahren
weggeht und sozusagen noch einzelne
geschäfte abwickelt das ist sicherlich
möglich dass werden den wirklichen und
auch einzelne geschäfte seien die
sozusagen im westlichen interesse sind
stichwort öl und gasimporte
beispielsweise deutschlands aus russland
ich glaube warum deutschland so lange
gezögert hat die regierung diesem
verzicht
oder diesem ausschluss ab hans lift
zuzustimmen ist die angst oder die sorge
vor der möglichen russischen
gegenreaktionen denn das eine ist ja
sozusagen dass wir mal irgendwann
vielleicht auf russisches öl und gas
verzichten können aber es ist ja dieser
eskalation systematik nicht gesagt dass
russland nicht seine exporte richtung
deutschland stock deutschland bekommt
über 50 prozent seiner gaslieferungen
aus russland die sind nicht kurzfristig
zu ersetzen man wird über den winter
kommen aber muss ich dann im sommer ganz
viel gedanken machen wo der nächste
winter so zu sagen da die gasversorgung
herkommt und auch öl ein drittel des der
ölimporte deutschlands kommt ebenfalls
aus russland also wenn da russland nicht
mehr liefert das wäre für deutschland
ganz harte konsequenz ganz herzlichen
dank für
die informationen die uns alle ja
irgendwann dann im zweifel auch
betreffen werden danke schön herr
weber gehen wir mal auf so eine
strategische ebene wo wir uns fragen
reagieren wir jetzt richtig
also wir haben ja eine eskalationsstufe
ich hab das ja jetzt gerade auch mit den
eltern besprochen eine eskalationsstufe
erreicht wo man nicht sehr viel mehr tun
kann also dieses schwert wie es genannt
wurde swift ist ein sehr scharfes
schwert da kann ich mir sie kommen ja
wahrscheinlich ist das aber richtig in
der jetzigen situation also dass ein
stufenweises einführen von sanktionen
hier nichts mehr nutzen kann das glaube
ich ist jetzt offenkundig geworden ein
stufenweises einführen von sanktionen
hätte dann sinn gehabt wenn putin
seinerseits in einer art von salami
taktik vorgegangen wäre ich hatte zum
beispiel erwartet dass dann nach dieser
unabhängigkeitserklärung für diese
republiken von der gans und dann jetzt
diese selbsternannten dass er
wahrscheinlich die ukraine aus den
ablass die dort heraus gedrängt hätte um
sozusagen diese ganzen republik gebiete
zu haben und dann innezuhalten und dann
vielleicht die nächste stufe zu machen
und stattdessen hat er mit voller wucht
mit der gesamten militärmacht der
russischen föderation drauf gehauen da
kann wahrscheinlich die sinnvolle
antwort auch nur noch sozusagen die
maximal therapie jetzt seien die man ihm
gedeihen so heißt das nicht umgekehrt
auch wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen
dass das eine lange planung voraus
gesetzt hat was jetzt die invasion
anbetrifft dass all diese maßnahmen die
reaktionen darauf eigentlich mit
eingeplant worden sind von russischer
seite ja die russen werden sich
sicherlich gedanken darüber gemacht
haben und sie werden in ihrem clan
spielen noch davon ausgegangen sein dass
das alles kommt die frage ist nur was
sie wirklich tun können er wird mit
gegen sanktionen antworten und ich halte
es für sehr wahrscheinlich dass es zu
einem stopp von gas- und öllieferungen
auch kommen wird das ist etwas was die
russen sicherlich gerne vermeiden würden
oder vielleicht muss man schon sein
vermieten hätten weil selbst in
sowjetischen zeiten ja immer zuverlässig
geliefert wurde also haben sie
allergrößten wert darauf gelegt weil sie
auch immer auf diese deviseneinnahmen
angewiesen waren damals wie heute dass
das läuft und dieser ruf dass man nicht
liefert und das zu einem politikum macht
das ist ein ruf den kann man einmal
zerstören dann ist als er stört aber
jetzt ist ein solcher scherbenhaufen da
in den beziehungen zwischen dem westen
und russland das ist da wahrscheinlich
putin nicht mehr darauf ankommt also ich
denke die gegen sanktionen wird kommen
aber ganz kurz sie haben das gerade
angedeutet das tut russland weh wenn es
nicht mehr liefert denn das ist das
kapital der russischen wirtschaft öl und
gas wobei das gas vielleicht ja eher für
europa wichtig ist aber das öl fließt
auch in die usa also das heißt für den
gesamten westen würde das ja nun eine
erhebliche einschränkung bedeuten ja und
das macht die ganze geschichte so
2schneidig also grundsätzlich trifft es
die russen sehr sehr hart man muss
wissen dass knapp 40 prozent der
russischen staatseinnahmen überhaupt aus
diesen diesem verkauf von eben höhere
karbonaten also von öl und gas stammen
nicht das muss man sich mal vorstellen
wenn ein 40 prozent der einnahmen
wegbrechen allerdings hat die russische
föderation ja um die 650 milliarden
dollar in der kriegskasse liegen dh das
kann man eine ganze zeit lang
durchhalten und umgekehrt wird uns das
sehr sehr weh tun wir haben es eben
bereits gehört von dem energieexperten
nicht wenn also diese lieferung nicht
mehr stattfinden diesen werden das
schaffen wir noch der sommer brauchen
wir nicht so furchtbar viel man habe es
müssen wir kommen im herbst wird sie
habe ich mir da muss man schnell
reagieren weber wir sprechen gleich
weiter wir wollen uns aber einmal
anschauen wir haben ja eben schon
darüber berichtet wie stark der
widerstand in der ukraine ist viel
größer als dass die russischen infos in
diejenigen die in die
ukraine einwandern wollten erwartet
haben
sie tun was sie können um den russischen
vormarsch aufzuhalten in der pro reifen
frauen und kinder am samstag styropor
stopfen es in bierflaschen
molotow-cocktails marke eigenbau auch
sie wollen helfen ihr land zu
verteidigen
neulich im leben vor der invasion war
irina englischlehrerin
niemand dachte dass wir unser wochenende
so verbringen würden aber jetzt scheint
es euch das einzig wichtige wir können
unser normales leben nicht leben selbst
wenn wir jetzt noch sicher sind wir
müssen etwas tun
noch sind die russischen truppen nicht
jedoch die ganze stadt ein strategisch
wichtiger knotenpunkt ist in aktion
spenden werden gesammelt männer und
frauen melden sich freiwillig an die
waffe um gegen putin soldaten zu kämpfen
er dachte wirklich er kann sich die
ukraine einfach so nehmen und in
russland verwandeln das ist nicht wahr
und es macht uns wirklich wütend
südlich von der pro heben freiwillige
gräben aus trainieren für den ernstfall
den sie unmittelbar erwarten ermutigt
von ihrem präsidenten der das land nicht
verlassen will
präsident biden hat unserem präsidenten
angeboten nach amerika zu gehen aber er
hat gesagt er bleibt bei uns wir fühlen
dass
der weg nach abo die cia führt am
wasserkraftwerk vorbei dass die sowjets
im zweiten weltkrieg zerstört haben um
den vormarsch der nazis zu stoppen wird
sich diese geschichte wiederholen
hinter der stadt ein checkpoint die
berichte von russischen verlusten lassen
die hoffnungen hier in den himmel
wachsen
nur der allmächtige weiß wann die russen
kommen denn sie werden geschlagen und
drehen sich im kreis sie kapieren dass
die ukraine von allen seiten auf sie
einschlägt
doch so groß die tapferkeit auch sein
mag lange werden sie die übermächtige
russische armee wohl kaum aufhalten
können die räder bünden in washington
schon guten abend
guten abend zunächst einmal an sie die
frage das ist eine internationale
vereinbarung der ausschluss russlands
auswirft das ist sicherlich auch einer
der schärfsten waffen die man überhaupt
hat das scheint jetzt die gesamte
gemeinsame linie aller länder auch der
usa zu sein
davon gehen wir aus denn präsident biden
war ja von journalisten als er das
letzte mal vor der präsentation
verkündet hat auch intensiv gefragt
wurden nach swift warum denn dieser
ausschluss noch nicht erfolgt sei und
daraufhin hatte er sich nicht
grundsätzlich ablehnend geäußert sondern
er hat ja gesagt diese option liegt
weiter auf dem tisch er hat halt nur
gesagt dass sich einige der europäischen
alliierten damit noch schwer tun wenn
jetzt diese
diese bedenken ausgeräumt sind dann kann
man erwarten dass die amerikaner damit
ziehen wie sie ja auch sonst auch bei
den direkten sanktionen gegen putin und
engel regierungsvertreter auch
mitgezogen haben hat es nochmal
ankündigungen von direkthilfen richtung
micro ukraine gegeben
ja die hat es in der tat gegeben gestern
abend hat präsident beiden ja ein 40
minütiges telefonate mit selensky
geführt und dabei ging es eben um
verteidigungs unterstützung und
anschließend hat er
350 millionen dollar in aussicht
gestellt eben für verteidigung der
außenminister blicken hat es heute noch
einmal konkretisiert hat gesagt ich soll
da zum beispiel gehen um abwehrwaffen
gegen panzer und gegen flugzeuge
insgesamt summiert sich jetzt die us
unterstützung für die ukraine seit
beginn 2021 auf eine milliarde dollar
die große frage ist nur wie schnell und
auf welchem weg können denn diese waffen
kann diese unterstützung in die ukraine
gelangen wir haben erfahren dass es
möglicherweise morgen eine un notfall
sicherheits sitzung geben wird das
sicherheitsrates das ist sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich das zeigt doch offenbar
auch die brisanz der augenblicklichen
lage
auf jeden fall es handelt sich dann um
die vierte dringlichkeitssitzung in
einer woche erst gestern ist ja eine
resolution die das russische vorgehen
scharf verurteilt gescheitert im
sicherheitsrat was jetzt keine
überraschung war denn die krieg führende
partei russland hat dort ja vetorecht
also entsprechend ist ja der
sicherheitsrat da gerade eher eine art
bühne und nicht unbedingt der ort an dem
konkrete entscheidungen getroffen werden
aber dennoch soll eben morgen
weitere dringlichkeitssitzung einberufen
werden für einen formalen schritt es
soll nämlich darüber abgestimmt werden
diese abgelehnte resolution in die un
vollversammlung zu überstellen
es gilt als sicher dass das gelingt und
dann wäre diese resolution am montag in
der vollversammlung der vereinten
nationen könnte dort mit einfacher
mehrheit angenommen werden und das wäre
dann wieder ein versuch druck auszuüben
aus ruß auf russland und zumindest in
einer symbolischen art und weise
russland auf der weltbühne weiter zu
isolieren frau bündnisse sind einige
jahre schon in den usa deswegen die
frage wenn sie mit amerikanern sprechen
ist die ukraine ein thema wie reagieren
die amerikaner
die amerikaner mögen helden und momentan
sind sie tatsächlich berührt von der
widerstandskraft des ukrainischen volkes
wie sich da die ganz normalen menschen
dieser übermacht der russischen armee
entgegen stellen das imponiert hier auch
der ukrainische präsident lenski
imponiert hier den menschen weil er sich
eben nicht von den amerikanern
evakuieren lässt also ich sehe hier
schon gerade eine emotionale
momentaufnahme es gibt eine aktuelle
umfrage dass mehr als 60 prozent der
amerikaner auch wirtschaftliche
sanktionen befürworten allerdings heißt
es nicht dass sie bereit sind zu
irgendwelchen kriegseinsätzen da ist die
nation doch sehr kriegsmüde und es
stellt sich die frage wie das dann
mittelfristig oder längerfristig
aussieht denn wenn man jetzt an staaten
denkt wie montana oder wyoming
also da ist die ukraine schon sehr sehr
weit weg und sehr viel konkreter ist da
eine andere sorge nämlich die vor
steigenden benzinpreisen die pins
benzinpreise sind hier bereits sehr hoch
waren sie schon vor der invasion
die inflation ist auf einem rekordhoch
seit 40 jahren und entsprechend ist das
eine sorge die die ganz normalen
amerikaner umtreibt die sie im
zweifelsfall präsident biden
anlasten wenn eben die preise da steigen
und das in einem wahljahr hier in den
usa also für die für den präsidenten
fürs weiße haus ist es auch durchaus
eine heikle situation
vielen dank für ihre bunten in
washington
und der polnische ministerpräsident
tadeusz mazowiecki hat sich geäußert und
hat darauf hingewiesen das nächste ziel
könnten die baltischen staaten polen
finnland oder auch andere länder an der
ostflanke sein putin will das russische
reich wieder herstellen das muss uns
allen große sorge machen unterdessen
berichten verschiedene medien über sehr
schwere russische angriffe die sich auch
auf kiew beziehen auch die region
luhansk und charkiw seien sehr schwer
von angriffen betroffen zurzeit sei eine
wahrscheinlich schwere nacht die der
ukraine bevorstünde wir schauen jetzt
auf den präsidenten der ukraine der sich
in den letzten tagen immer wieder
teilweise mit seinem eigenen handy
gefilmt hat um zu dokumentieren er
bleibt in der ukraine und will
widerstand lassen
die bereitschaft der ukraine das eigene
land zur verteidigung unserer
solidarität miteinander und das freiheit
haben das szenario den aggressoren
zerstört ukraine sind stark ukraine
können ukrainerin tapfer sie befindet
sich auf ihrem eigenen land und sie
werden niemals irland jemanden abgeben
und lag nie verraten und deswegen ist es
kein zufall dass bei solchen menschen
auch die freunde stärker sind als die
feinde ich habe wieder mit den führern
anderer starter gesprochen mit freunden
ein gutes ergebnis war mein gespräch mit
italien das gespräch mit mario draghi
mit dem
präsidenten der italienischen republik
hat alles richtig gestellt auch mit dem
indischen premierminister putin habe ich
auch gesprochen über unsere abwehr der
aggressoren ich bedanke mich auch bei
unseren freunden sogar dafür dass er
immer unsere unabhängigkeit und unsere
territoriale integrität unterstützt
jetzt ist sehr wichtig dass er jetzt
geschlossen hat für durchgang der
russischen schiffe durch die meerenge im
schwarzen meer
von aserbaidschan
mit dem habe ich auch gesprochen ich
habe mit ihm gesprochen dass er unserem
land kein öl gibt und nicht ausreichend
öl produkte gibt aber es wird alles
hat versprochen die sich verhandlungen
mit russland zu organisieren
premierminister griechenland auch der
schweiz und alles haben dass die
gespräche mit diesen türen haben
bewiesen dass die ukraine aufmerksamkeit
der ganzen welt an sich gezogen und es
wurden war viele bedingungen sanktionen
gegen die russische föderation
ausscheidung
allgemeinen zivilisation und wir hoffen
dass alle staaten der welt die gerechte
entscheidung getroffen haben russland
von swift einzuschalten es geht hier
über milliardenverluste für russland das
ist ein konkreter preis für diese
hinterhältige aggression in unserem
staat wir haben immer gesagt mit uns ist
die wahrheit und das bedeutet dass die
großen errungenschaften erreicht werden
ich habe heute gesprochen mit den
führern der kirchen mit den vertretern
der orthodoxen kirche und
franziska oberhaupt der katholische
kirche anführer der kirche beten für
unser verteidigung
dies sind im geiste mit denen und beten
für die seelen der helden die ihr leben
für unser land hergegeben haben und das
ist sehr wichtig heute haben wir in kiew
einen schönen sonnigen tag die besitzer
haben versucht uns diesen tag zu
zerstören wie auch alles in der
geschichte unseres landes aber heute ist
auch der erste tag des lebens eines
kleinen mädchen das heute nacht in der
u-bahn in kiew geboren wurde das ist
jetzt unser versteckt wir geben unsere
antwort würde würdige antwort das sehen
wir alles in nachrichten- und ich kann
ihnen noch eins sagen wir werden so
lange kämpfen bis wir unser land befreit
haben und das heißt unser kinder werden
bereits in der u-bahn geboren und und
wenn das so passiert so hat der feind
keine chance
ja ich hatte gerade
präsident jens g am telefon und ich muss
sagen es läuft alles gar nicht im sinne
von präsident putin ganz und gar nicht
die bevölkerung der ukraine kämpfte
heroisch und an manchen orten sogar mit
viel erfolg und damit hatten wir
gerechnet ein großes volk ein tolles
land und wie sie zu recht gesagt haben
werden da wirkliche gräueltaten begangen
und ich glaube die ukraine hat wirklich
düstere tage und zeiten vor sich aber
wir tun alles was in unserer macht steht
um diese schwierigen umstände zu
verändern und ihnen zu helfen
wir haben humanitäre
humanitäre hilfe geschickt
finanzielle hilfe und auch militärische
unterstützung und das ist wichtig und
das vereinigte königreich war im übrigen
das erste europäische land das überhaupt
militärische hilfe in die ukraine
geschickt hat gestern abend sind viele
andere weitere länder dazu gekommen und
haben auch solche zusagen gemacht sie
sehen wir werden immer mehr und
ich kann nur sagen ja wir müssen
sichergehen dass wir noch strengere
wirtschaftliche sanktionen anwenden
insbesondere auch was das subsystem
angeht denn
dieser horror der da gerade vor unseren
augen sich entfaltet muss auch dem
westlichen publikum klar gemacht werden
denn das wiederum führt noch zu mehr
druck auf westliche politiker und
politikerinnen und wir müssen das
zusammen und besser machen warum nehmen
sie nicht ab flüchtlinge auf natürlich
neben der flüchtlinge auf dieses land
hat eine historische tradition in der
aufnahme von flüchtlingen aus vielen
konflikten weltweit denken sie an
afghanistan zb das vereinigte königreich
war da ganz vorne dabei und da hat es im
internet wirklich gezielte
falschinformationen gegeben und da habe
ich schon korrigiert natürlich sind wir
bereit schlecht flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
wir haben auch schon 1000 mann vor ort
entsendet und natürlich helfen wir auch
denjenigen die aus angst um ihr leben
ziehen
nun was glauben sie die ganze diplomatie
ist sie zum scheitern
verurteilt
nun die realität ist scheußlich sie ist
furchtbar und ich muss sagen vonseiten
putin war die diplomatie eine reine
charade er hatte niemals vor seinen kurs
zu ändern von seinem plan abzuweichen er
hat das schon vor monaten entschieden
er ist in einer semi mystischen
komischen vision der geschichte
verfangen und die
ukrainische bevölkerung
lehnt dieses bild inbrünstig und
leidenschaftlich ab und wir müssen alles
tun diese schwierigen umstände zu
verändern und deswegen auch unsere
unterstützung sie haben das hilfssystem
erwähnt müssen wir noch mehr tun um auch
andere länder dazu auf zu fördern ja
aber allein was heute passiert ist mehr
und mehr länder sind dem aufruf des
vereinigten königreichs gefolgt es hilft
ist ein system damit kann man dem system
von putin und dem russland von putin
keine zahlungen mehr
schicken und wir müssen einfach diese
diese störung um die russische
volkswirtschaft noch verstärken und auch
frankreich
ist jetzt dafür
was uns sport angeht
zb es gibt einige länder die diese
sportveranstaltungen ablehnen ja es ist
völlig unvorstellbar es ist traurig
hatten wir eine solche situation schon
mal neun jahre lang nicht aber ich kann
es mir nicht vorstellen dass normale
sportveranstaltungen mit putins russland
weiter gehen können ist es nicht
enttäuschend dass länder wie china sich
enthalten haben und diese illegale
anlasslose invasion nicht verurteilt
haben und was wir heute erleben
oder in den letzten stunden ist doch
dass weltweit ein bewusstsein dafür
entsteht dass das ein horror ist mit dem
niemand gerechnet hat und
dieses bewusstsein wächst nicht nur in
ländern
außerhalb europas aber vor allem auch in
russland selbst und die länder die
bislang eher phlegmatisch waren
sehen jetzt auch dass die gräueltaten
von russland in der ukraine mehr und
mehr diskutiert werden und in der
zwischenzeit tun wir alles um unseren
freunden und freundinnen in der ukraine
zur seite zu stehen wieweit schätzen sie
den eindruck ein den ein solche
solidarität des westens auf wladimir
putin macht
ich schätze dass aber das ist ein
bisschen lesen der glaskugel als gering
ein ich glaube nicht dass das den
russischen präsidenten beeindruckt das
ändert aber nichts dass solche aktionen
dass solche sanktionen die
voraussetzungen oder die grundlage
ändern mit der wir in die nächste phase
eintreten also die frage was kommt denn
nach dem krieg mit dem wesentlichen
dadurch bestimmt was wir jetzt
eigentlich tun dass vorzubereiten also
wir werden diesen krieg der jetzt gerade
läuft dadurch beeinflussen aber den nach
diesen schießt krieg folgenden konflikt
und die frage wie gehen wir in zukunft
mit russland umgehen beeinflussen wir
damit sehr wohl wir haben also erst mit
einem mittelfristig langfristig
wirksamen instrumenten des kindes
kurzfristig wirksam haben wir sehr viel
schon in den letzten tagen die
diskussion erlebt zum thema
realitätsverlust des westens hat man
russland falsch eingeschätzt
also die ein jahr die andern 1 ich
glaube man muss glaube ich da auch auf
der einen seite sehen dass wir es damit
zu tun haben dass eine neue
bundesregierung erst mal tritt fassen
muss zweitens sie auch den
koalitionsfrieden uns einige parteien
ihren partei frieden sichern müssen wir
können nur hoffen dass die wie soll man
sagen die wendungen der letzten 24
stunden die passiert sind innerhalb der
bundesregierung die klarheit mit der man
sich jetzt geäußert hat dass die bleiben
und dass sie nicht ein so ein kurzer
moment sind und diese teilweise rund 80
grad wendungen morgen schon wieder sich
um 180 grad drehen und wie im grunde
genommen die glaubwürdigkeit
deutschlands komplett dann aufs spiel
gesetzt haben musiker verloren haben
aber irgendwie haben sie denn in den
letzten 4 hat man muss schon fast sagen
jahren
dieses fast um verständnis heischende
empfinden von manchen in talkshows
empfunden die immer wieder gesagt haben
ja man muss putin verstehen und wir
gehen falsch mit ihm um und man muss ihm
im grunde genommen mehr raum einräumen
im sinne von ihnen mehr hören man muss
mehr auf ihn zugehen
war dass möglicherweise eine völlige
fehleinschätzung
ich fand dass vor allen dingen
geschichtsvergessen weil es bedeutet
dass man all die schritte die nach dem
ende des kalten krieges auf russland zu
gemacht worden sind nicht in betracht
gezogen hat wir haben mit dem mit der
nato russland grundakten einen
grundlegenden vertrag geschlossen
zwischen russland und der nato darüber
wie wir in zukunft miteinander umgehen
wollen wir haben dabei sogar als nato
darauf verzichtet substanzielle
kampftruppen auf dem gebiet der neuen
nato ländern nämlich als zum beispiel
polen zu stationieren
und das fällt uns dann letztendlich auf
die füße ich kann das alles verstehen
weil das alles in einem geist passiert
ist wo wir in den anfang 90er 90er
jahren auch darüber gesprochen haben
dass russland sogar mitglied der nato
werden könnte das kann man sich heute
gar nicht mehr vorstellen bei der
eskalation der wir drin sind aber das
ist der geist bedient mir damals gelebt
haben und von daher kann ich diese idee
man hätte muss halt hier sozusagen auf
die füße getreten oder was auch immer
erstens nicht verstehen und zweitens das
als legitimation für einen angriffskrieg
zu nutzen ist ehrlich gesagt absurd
wenn sie gesagt haben zu beginn man kann
da nicht in die glaskugel schauen was
muss ich denn letztendlich ändern wenn
es zu einer zu einem waffenstillstand
kommt zu einer beruhigung möglicherweise
der situation oder im zweifel sogar zu
einer kompletten einnahme der ukraine
wie muss der westen mit russland umgehen
ich glaube sie hat sehr gut beschrieben
es gibt sehr unterschiedliche szenarien
ob die wir uns einstellen müssen
das eine ist es gelingt russland jetzt
doch relativ schnell die ukraine
anzunehmen zurzeit sieht es nicht danach
aus es gibt das welche variante einen
abnutzungskrieg der irgendwann auch
russland zu stark unter druck setzt dass
man quasi einen waffenstillstand
verhandeln muss unter gleichen das was
wir in den letzten tagen gesehen haben
die angebote zur verhandlung
sonderangebot ist der kapitulation
gewesen das gehört ja nicht mit rein
verhandlung unter gleichen
das wäre eine andere möglichkeit die
dritte möglichkeit die ich allerdings
auch was ausschließen würde wäre die
möglichkeit dass die ukraine das
tatsächlich geschafft erfolgreich die
russischen kräfte weitgehend zurück zu
drängen aber auf alle diese drei
szenarien muss man sich im grunde um
auch als westen und auch wir als
deutschland einstellen und ich glaube
dass der wesentliche punkte in allen
drei szenarien zutrifft ist die ukraine
braucht um danach weitermachen zu können
massive finanzielle unterstützung und
auch politische unterstützung des
militärisch lasse ich jetzt einfach mal
raus aber diese beiden sachen sind
wichtig denn das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dieses land hat sich
frühzeitig in richtung europa und
europäische union entschieden
die jetzt vor der haustür stehen zu
lassen ist aus meiner sicht keine
weitere option die man hier ziehen kann
ich glaube da müssen wir ganz klar
machen auch um die werte die wird seit
unserer aussenpolitik vertreten wollen
klar zu machen dass man tatsächlich hier
die tür nach europa für die ukraine in
unter allen bedingungen die ich ihm
geschildert habe offen halten muss man
in vielen dank ich danke ihnen
die ukrainische botschafterin in
washington oxana makarowa hat sich heute
dazu geäußert was in ihrem land passiert
und welche schäden jetzt nach drei tagen
invasion der russischen truppen
entstanden sind
seine für brite aggression weiter
durchgeführt um den frieden und die
sicherheit in unseren städten zu
untergraben
es gibt gruppen überall in der ukraine
und unsere mutigen
und unsere streitkräfte spüren diese
gruppen auf um sie dann auszuschalten
der cyber krieg wird fortgeführt diese
cyber attacken hatten wir ja schon vor
beginn des krieges und ab dem ersten tag
des krieges und nach den berichten der
sicherheitsdienst ist es so dass die
besatzer
gasmasken aus teilen an die bevölkerung
und an das russische militär wir
machen diese information öffentlich weil
wir fürchten dass es vielleicht
provokationen gibt und es besteht
durchaus die möglichkeit dass industrie
tanks mit chemikalien gesprengt werden
dann
wird
sabotage durchgeführte die russen
beschuldigen uns dass wir das tun würden
aber wir tun so etwas nicht unsere
streitkräfte verhalten sich
verantwortungsbewusst und verteidigen
unser land und versuchen wirklich
gleichzeitig auf verantwortungsvoll mit
den organischen bürgern umzugehen weil
unsere streitkräfte natürlich unser land
und unsere bürger
verteidige und müssen die russischen
truppen bombardieren weiterhin
militärische strukturen und zunehmend
zivile strukturen
attraktive und kiew wurden bombardiert
und gerade in der letzten nacht und
gestern haben viele familien ihre
unterkünfte
verloren die russische seite hat die
schlangen insel im schwarzen meer
angegriffen
man hat das
kernkraftwerk von tschernobyl
übersetzte und man hat auf die region
jedenfalls teilweise besetzt und auch
den
die f kanal erreicht gleichzeitig wurde
der
damm zerstört
wir verfolgen das ganze aufmerksamkeit
ist aufmerksam zu ermöglichen
das ist zu überflutungen kommt
der visko rotterdam ist auch ins visier
der russischen truppen geraten da
besteht die gefahr dass das kraftwerk
zur polka betroffen wird am 25
februar wurden zwei
zivile und stifte unter der flagge von
panama und moldau durch russische
kriegsschiffe angegriffen das ist ein
verstoß gegen das internationale
seerecht jetzt möchte ich mich aber
stärker auf die verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
konzentrieren über die die tat von
männer und frauen die als reporter vor
ort in berichten der welt berichten über
die geschehnisse vor ort wir sind völlig
empört angesichts der russischen
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit in
den letzten 72 stunden hat die russische
armee
kindergarten und waisenhäuser angeknüpft
hinter mir sehen sie bilder davon von
diesen russischen
kriegsverbrechen dann wurde die stadt
zur türkei angegriffen mit hail
raketenwerfer dabei wurden mehrere
kinder verletzt und ein siebenjähriges
mädchen des zunächst verletzt wurde
starb danach später
80 prozent in der
wohngebiete in krakau wurden zerstört
und unsere gedanken sind bei den
bewohner in dieser stadt dann wurde ein
weißen haus getroffen 50 kinder befanden
sich in dem waisenheim und trotz sei
dank
sind sie unverletzt geblieben dann sagt
arno im raum von donetsk und summe
wurden gegenstand von intensiven
bonbons die russische armee versuchte
ihre kriegsverbrechen
zu verstecken aber zusammen im
generalstaatsanwalt sammeln wir beweise
und übermitteln dass alles nach den haag
denn die verantwortung für diese aktion
die müssen sie tragen selbst wenn es
lange dauert bis wir unser land
verteidigt haben natürlich gibt es auch
verluste auf der ukrainischen seite
stand 26
februar haben wir viele unserer tapfer
und söhne und töchter verloren
198 wurden getötet darunter drei kinder
1115 verletzte darunter 33 kinder zivile
verluste belaufen sich auf 38 davon sind
zwei kinder
und
es wurden sehr viele menschen
natürlich verletzt aber wie sie das auch
sehen können anhand des videomaterials
aus der ukraine sind millionen von
ukrainer betroffen durch diesen krieg
die menschen verbringen tag und nacht in
den bunkern babys werden dort geboren
die kinder können nicht in die schule
gehen und viele versuchen ihre kinder
entweder in die west ukraine zu
evakuieren oder in ein nachbarland
jedenfalls zeitweilig und die männer
kehre nach hause zurück um zu kämpfen
das ist eine riesige humanitäre
katastrophe im zentrum europas dann darf
ich ihnen auch
berichten dass der feind natürlich auch
nicht ungestraft davonkommt in den
letzten tagen haben auch in der zwei
panzer vernichtet 14 kampfjets und
hubschrauber
15 artilleriestellung ein buch ein
system und 506 und
836 gepanzerte fahrzeuge und als
ergebnis der ruchlosen entscheidung von
präsident
putin
seine soldaten in diesen kriminellen
krieg zu schicken
werden
3500 russische soldaten nicht nach hause
zurückkehren gestern hat unsere
vize-ministerpräsidentin für die
besetzten gebiete und die integration
des donners erinnerte
an das rote kreuz appelliert
damit es hilft bei der rückführung
dieser russischen leichname zurück nach
russland
wir sind sehr dankbar für die
unterstützung
der anti kriegs koalition
73 länder ich habe das gestern ja schon
gesagt sind beteiligt und neun
internationale organisationen sie alle
sind teil dieser koalition
und wir bekommen noch zusätzliche waffen
zusätzliche munition und wir bekommen
finanzielle und humanitäre hilfe und
besonders wichtig ist dass wir gemeinsam
uns für nachträgliche sanktionen
einsetzen bei dieser gelegenheit möchte
ich wirklich alle auffordern entschieden
aufzutreten bei den sanktionen und alle
sanktionen auch umzusetzen
die russland und putin verdienen für das
was sie der ukraine antun und dem
frieden die sanktionen sollten auch
harte finanzielle
sanktionen umfassen wir meinen alle
finanzinstitutionen den russland sollten
sanktioniert werden
abgeschaltet werden vom großteil der
international organisation im grunde von
der zivilisierten welt und wir haben ja
gestern bei der sitzung des
sicherheitsrates der vereinten nationen
gesehen dass uns land wieder einmal ein
veto eingelegt hatte gegen eine
entscheidung
zur beendigung der russischen aggression
und zur herstellung des friedens
abschließend darf ich sagen dass die
stimmung der geist der streitkräfte der
nationalgarde des grenzschutzes all
unserer mutigen männer und frauen und
der bürger insgesamt
sehr hoch ist wir haben ja im letzten
jahr das schon gesagt und wir haben das
auch wiederholt als wir gesehen haben
dass putin jetzt diese entscheidung
getroffen hat auf die er sich ja seit
geraumer zeit vorbereitet hat und in den
letzten drei tagen haben wir ja gezeigt
wir sind entschlossen sehr entschlossen
unser land zu verteidigen
die leute kommen in die ukraine zurück
obwohl es schwierig ist weil es keine
flüge in der ukraine gibt aber menschen
aus allen teilen der welt kommen nach
hause um unser land zu verteidigen und
wir werden uns auch weiterhin tun und
wir hoffen wirklich dass die gesamte
zivilisierte welt nicht nur an unserer
seite steht wir jetzt auch sondern dass
wir
gemeinsam herrn putin stoppen kann damit
wieder frieden in unserem land und in
europa herrscht und damit die ukraine
weiterhin ein souveränes land bleibt in
frieden sowie dass unsere bürger sich
wünschen da kommen wir noch mal zur
humanitären seite wir haben etwa 200
russische
soldaten gefangen genommen einige davon
19 jahre gar nicht ausgebildet schlecht
ausgerüstet wir behandeln sie nach den
bestimmungen der genfer konvention und
dem internationalen menschenrecht wir
können ihnen auch youtube
clips zur verfügung stellen sie haben
die möglichkeit ihre eltern anzurufen
sie bekommen lebensmittel und wasser und
wie gesagt sie werden nach der genfer
konvention behandelt
weil wir es weiter hinten joachim weber
sicherheitsexperte und gastprofessor an
der universität bonn wir haben jetzt
ganz kurz noch mal am schluss der
darstellung gehört wie die situation der
russischen soldaten aussieht wir haben
sehr viele informationen über schäden
bekommen was ist von diesen aussagen zu
halten dass es ganz schwer
einzuschätzende moment weil
kriegführenden parteien grundsätzlich
die dinge so darzustellen versuchen wie
sie den eindruck nach außen sozusagen
auch erzeugen wollen insofern würde ich
solche angaben egal von welcher seite
immer mit großer vorsicht genießen
wollen
was die verluste der russen angeht wenn
es so ist wie die ukrainische
botschafter in washington gesagt hat
dann wären diese verluste sehr hoch es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass das so ist
weil ja und die ukraine auch gerade in
den letzten wochen noch relativ stark
mit waffen munitionslieferungen aus den
usa bedacht worden ist ist sind aus den
usa und aus großbritannien diese jeff
lynne panzerabwehrraketen geliefert
worden also das sind so fire and forget
waffen man braucht sich nicht erinnern
das heißt man braucht sich nicht da
hinstellen wie bisher mit einer
panzerfaust warten dass der 100 meter
vor ihm ist nicht und dann den
anvisieren da kann man auch schon längst
erschossen worden sein von der begleit
im vertrieb die kann man ab schießen das
ist fire und folgert man feuer das ding
ab aus irgendetwas gedeckten geschützten
stellung und dann legt er los und sucht
sich den panzer selbst das ist übergeben
bedeutender schritt weiter die haben die
ukraine jetzt und insofern ist das
zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen dass sie
solche abschusszahlen erreicht haben
könnten dann werden das sehr sehr
empfindliche verluste fließen wir haben
sehr viel aus russland gehört über neue
waffen die dort entwickelt worden sind
hyperschall waffen etc
wie ist denn die
militärische ausstattung in russland
also aus diesem sektor angeht neue
hochtechnologie waffen ist russland
wahrscheinlich den westen ein stückchen
enteilt wir wissen nicht so ganz genau
was davon wirklich funktioniert was
davon wirklich gefechts tauglich ist die
calida raketen sind es auf jeden fall
aber das ist im grunde eher ein
russisches nachziehen zu sachen die die
amerikaner schon seit langem haben wie
die vitadock flugkörper afrikanischer
seite was neue dinge angeht die
überseeischen flugkörper die somit
sieben bis zehn schallgeschwindigkeit
fliegen
können wenn sie so funktionieren
anscheinend haben die russen die jetzt
einigermaßen im griff das ist eine
gefährliche neuentwicklung da hat der
westen nichts vergleichbares personal
und auch kaum möglichkeiten diese
flugkörper abzufangen aber die frage ist
in welchem ausmaß in welcher zahl sie
wirklich verfügbar sind schon für die
russen aber bei all diesen systemen die
proteine da hat entwickeln lassen den
jüngsten jahren handelt es sich um
strategische waffen das ist etwas
anderes als das was jetzt hier
taktischen operativ auf dem gefechtsfeld
eingesetzt wird das uns strategische
waffen und sie dienen vor allen dingen
dazu die zweite oder gar dritte schlag
fähigkeit der der russischen föderation
sicher zu stellen weil die russen sich
eben durch
andere ballistic missile systeme die
also ihre zweite schlag fähigkeit zu
unterminieren drohte neben bedroht
fühlten und abgehängt fühlten nicht und
die russen wollen unter allen umständen
die strategische nukleare zweite schlag
kapazität erhalten dazu dienen diese
dinge gebe werde noch mal auf diese
eskalation ein die wir jetzt gerade
beobachten wir haben jetzt gerade eine
meldung rein bekommen dass der luftraum
über der bundesrepublik für russische
maschinen gesperrt werden soll das hat
bundesverkehrsminister volker wissing
erklärt wir haben ja auf beiden seiten
will ich mal zu sagen wenn man das als
zwei seiten beschreiben mag eine
ständige neue eskalation
erreicht das geht auch in einer kürzeren
abschnitten so weiter
wie kann man denn diese möglichkeit
finden jetzt auf die bremse zu treten
und wer würde es von beiden seiten tun
ja das ist ganz ganz schwer weil die
situation unglaublich verfahren das
daran ist kein kein zweifel und es wäre
wahrscheinlich aus der sicht beider
seiten ein großes prestige verlust wenn
man jetzt dem anderen anbieten würde na
ja wir denken jetzt mal einen nicht es
wird uns hier ein bisschen heiß
miteinander also das ist im moment nicht
zu sehen dass da einer den ersten
schritt tut der westen kann es nicht tun
weil die russen eindeutig der aggressor
sind in diesem fall man kann also nicht
sagen wir nehmen diese aggressionen
jetzt in irgendeiner weise nicht mehr
ernst naja und putin hat alles auf diese
eine karte gesetzt das ist ja das
schlimme an dieser ganzen situation und
ich hatte wirklich inständig gehofft
dass er damit irgend einem symbolischen
schritt sich begnügen würde ich hatte ja
bereits erwähnt die die anerkennung ist
republiken da habe ich gedacht wir sind
sozusagen mit einem kleinen auge noch
mal davongekommen aber das hielt nur
stunden und dann ging es weiter und er
hat alles auf diese karte gesetzt und es
wird für ihn deswegen ungeheuer schwer
zurückzukommen ein ausweg den könnte ich
darin sehen dass zum beispiel seine
chinesischen freunde mit denen er ja
inzwischen sehr ein verwandeltes dass
die kommen und sagen hier ja auf
empfehlungen oder bitten was auch immer
des chinesischen präsidenten nicht ist
er putin bereit in irgendeiner weise mit
sich reden zu lassen nicht und das
versucht so ein bisschen ohne
gesichtsverlust dazu gehören gerade
sagen das ist vor allen dingen der
ausweg auch für wladimir putin der
geschaffen werden muss aus der position
im augenblick kommt er ja kaum raus
lassen wir ganz kurz noch auf die rolle
chinas noch mal eingehen sie sagen das
könnte eine möglichkeit sein welche
rolle spielt china wirklich wir haben
gestern im un-sicherheitsrat
beziehungsweise heute nacht gesehen dass
china sich enthalten hat einer
resolution gegen
russland das ist so eine halb und halb
position will ich mal sagen es war keine
position die russland komplett gestärkt
hat ja ich habe es ja heute auch schon
so bewertet und habe gesagt ich bin sehr
erleichtert und erfreut darüber dass die
chinesen sich zumindest zur enthaltung
entschlossen haben das verhältnis
zwischen beiden ländern ist ja in den
vergangenen jahren extrem eng geworden
und
wir haben eine situation die
grundsätzlich so ist dass china der
stärkere partner ist und junior eigene
russland eigentlich der juniorpartner
darin das heißt russland braucht die
anlehnung an china aber china braucht
keine anlehnung an russland aber beide
zusammen sind natürlich doch unglaublich
stark das chinesische
wirtschaftspotenzial und das russische
militär potenzial insofern aber wegen
der größeren abhängigkeit der russen von
china kann china einfluss nehmen wenn
china das will es ist vielleicht ein
erster schritt eben dass china sich
enthalten hat und nicht bedingungslos
wladimir putin rücken gestärkt hat
vielleicht sind die chinesen die auch
merken es kommt sozusagen die ganze welt
hier in eine gefährdung damit kommt auch
der weitere aufstieg chinas zur
supermacht vielleicht zu beherrschenden
supermacht auf diesem planeten in gefahr
wenn wir hier auf einem großen globalen
krieg zu steuern sollten an der stelle
müssen die chinesen interessiert werden
auch wladimir putin einzubremsen und es
wäre ein wunderbarer weg weil auch china
dann als friedensstifter dastehen würde
wenn ich in diesen kommen würden sagen
würden ja wir haben eine einer
es ist unsere bitte gewesen dass der
russische präsident in verhandlungen
eintreten polizei habe ich bin ich bin
bereit dazu den den wünschen und bitten
meine chinesischen partner nationen
sprechen dann kommt da mit relativ
kleinen gesichtsverlust heraus und kann
vielleicht die palme wieder runter
klettern wir müssen uns jetzt auch aus
psychologischen gründen so langsam
einige auswege aus denken denn die
situation ist schwer erträglich
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns
waren meine damen und herren und wir
setzen natürlich das programm fort und
werden am thema ukraine nicht
vorbeikommen mein kollege david damschen
hat eine chronologie dieser ersten tage
des krieges um die ukraine zusammen
gestellt und darauf folgt ein gespräch
mit dem ehemaligen botschafter in moskau
rüdiger von fritsch der sehr genau
beschreiben kann wie sich auch die
situation sagen wir mal aussagen treffen
mit wladimir putin entwickelt hat und im
zweifel auch verändert hat wir sind auf
jeden fall auch wieder da heute nämlich
um 11 uhr da gibt es die sondersitzung
des deutschen bundestages als war ein
danke für ihr interesse